è totalmente invisibile non si muove va
bene la risata di nove ti prego posso
mettere il video con apice pietro e c'è
anche bob grazie grazie grande bot e c'è
anche da lazard che purtroppo c'è anche
pietro però si giochi in qua allora
andiamo su pronto ben signorello
fallimento come parlare come me sono le
stesse alle sei di sera
certo maghetti gut incredibile come fare
sta roba
non è che cosa sia ora di evitare di
essere lui e vieni pop è stata chi giura
non ho mai visto una cosa così bella da
quando gioco a farlo
pietro e fuori subito perfetta perché
dobbiamo seguirla io ti voto dice a casa
che ha il tetto
cosa c'è un po di gente ragazzi studenti
gente gente esempio gli utenti centro
gioco a calcio vieni qua pietroiusti
importane arriva un tipo che spara
picchio vicchio fi giochetto sono sicuro
che sto picchiando hai mai abbia fatto
fare picchio pietro medica vi si un buon
amico vendico il carrista schivando
tutti coltivava sarebbe stato bellissimo
no sono moto di nuovo
infatti due arrivo lorenzo ematico
accanto all'altra ma niente e quindi
hanno fatto anche non muoverti non
muoverti hai capito
c'è la guerra dei mondi è totalmente
invisibile mag
quel tizio nero di fronte alle ha
scoraggiato e abbastanza ceco non si
muove
va bene
aguero è stato bellissimo e stata la
cosa più bella però proprio nella ma
piano piano verso la volta veloce lo
scisma stradivari
posso dire una cosa presidente le dona
particolarmente questo cespugli la
ringrazio perché poi ci sfugge che la
città non sono fatti così ma non se ne
accorgono
no mi hanno visto per eccoti eccoli acli
che attraversano la musica non è
adeguato george sta più bel ami fare un
sistema e poi continua perché city però
bicicletta non ho fatto io dico che non
solo deve andare l'aiuto c'è un tizio
che si è schiantato per terra noi
sfondiamo il tetto prendiamo un po un
país fondiamo la testa serio spero
brutto oggi altra partenza ragazzi
un'intervista con in caso di frana o che
hanno portato un altro che sparano 54 4
nov ap aiuta bambini aiutano a mantova
mn talvolta bordo bob ti prego aiutatemi
aiutatemi sono solo
aiuto sono ancora vivo non so come non
lo so aiutate gli altri tempo come fare
secondo presidianti capitemi grazie ma
da è vero
l'hack è male che vale bob d'elba la mia
guardia del box svitato figure sono
finito a terra io fatto ci vuole una
bella colonna musicale
[Musica]
per lavorare bene dentro casa ecco
quindi se grazie per scurire vieni
canili assai fa cosa aspetta cody ross
[Musica]
500 che ha finito in questo periodo va
bene chi è che manca in tutto questo
secondo me lega no perché è stato bob
poi i ragazzi stanno un po in ritardo
quelli poi ci sono addirittura due
forzieri qui come divorata a eccole
domestico stiani
[Musica]
ti senti senti anche giunto per cir i
bagagli
moltissimi di questi non stavo capello
ma questa è misto che doveva schiava
ragazzi mi rendete orgogliosa di
inserire fini mi divido fantastico sto
vedendo uno scudo sulla schiena della
spalla destra è presidente
ora spetta ad ora in che punto del
progetto chiamato entrambi con chendo
tecnico quindi un altro nostro favore
ecco questo vale più forti
mamma mia bene qui da quello che balla
[Musica]
prega checa cosa stiamo giocando ma che
meraviglia termine ma se stai andando
storto ci sparano alla data stesso team
aspar ha toccato il pallone piccolo ma
resta sempre in mongoloide guardali che
torni indietro sembra c'è un presidente
di gas paga qua sono qua
si vuole fare le cose sporche web cosa
facile da garantirsi una bomba cliente
vabbè non possono le cose bruttissime
che me ne vado cambia gioco io e tutta
ma quelli lascia procuratevi river è
vero o no
non saprei testa regata voi vedete ve
l'ho detto tutto il biglietto urca la
spacca
pietro tutto questo dove sta minkia 6
spara bravo pietro bonomo riconoscendovi
legacy sarà anche la casa arriva anche
se arriva lo so
minchia non ce la facciamo paura io
dentro che hai visto se rimane meglio
prescindere distruggete cecchino
distruggete fisici fino a quella destra
quel abbiamo risultati astra anche
stavolta festa quando li vedi è vero ho
capito la portata a terra sarà forte
york
ma questo sono forte porca vacca nuovo
visto niente
nonostante l'avviso sugli spazi
chiacchierato come persona messo
malissimo amico no no il presidente
aiutate mostrano volta che scende in q1
sempre gli altri o guardo gli altri
vince non voglio dare bello in un sito
di questo può ancora fare con
lanciarazzi spetta arrivo quest'anno è
l'ultimo è l'ultimo figlio davide bene
bene
sono morto so io il fatto è che se mi si
switch e al colore della pelle perché
unisco più partite insieme cosa che ho
sempre fatto solo che supporta ed ogni
volta cambia il personaggio quindi da
una scena all'altra passo da da uomo
donna nero bianco verde un casino con i
ragazzi spero vi sia piaciuto non mi
piace soprattutto per bob che si è
offerto di farmi da bodyguard in questo
video il cespuglio è stata la cosa più
bella che sia mai successa su ford ha
età quando ci gioco quasi ragazzi ci
vediamo al prossimo visto dai ragazzi
[Musica]